♪ [upbeat music plays]
Jessica Tran: Mobile ASL is
an experimental application
that provides real-time sign language
communication on cell phones.
So this allows deaf people to communicate
in real-time using their mobile devices.
And what makes us unique is
that we're able to transmit video
at very low bandwidth
using the 3G cellular network.
Jaehong Chon: Well, about five years ago,
we started the project for
different operating systems,
but essentially we switched to Android
because the most people used the Android
device than other existing platform.
And then, the Android API
Android environment
is much easier than other operating system.
So I can easily access
to front-facing camera.
I can easily access to some API
to display the video
to send the data through the network.
Jessica Tran: Since we're only
sending video,
we're able to toss out the audio.
So that already removes a lot of the data.
And we're doing a lot of different video
compression techniques to send the video.
For instance, we're sending video
at 30 Kilobits per second
at 15 frames per second.
And we also do region
of interest encoding.
So we identify the skin pixels,
such as the hands and the face,
and when we transmit the video,
there are more pixels devoted to
there as opposed to the background.
So, the hands and the face
are more clear,
but the background is sacrificed.
Which is fine,
because it's really important for
people to see what's being conveyed
through the hands and the face.
Jaehong Chon: Basically, there are a lot
of applications for the same purpose,
like Skype, iPod, some of this program.
But none of them provide the same
accessibility through the cellular network.
So our goal is to provide the same
capability anywhere, anytime.
00:01:48.750,00:00:00.000